[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
le football c'est sa vie l' aj auxerre
son club de coeur et il en a fait de
l'or il l'a fait entrer dans la cour des
grands le doublé historique de 96 c'est
avec lui vainqueur de la coupe de france
est premier du championnat de france
alors comment at il fait eh bien il
avait des méthodes bien à lui il
espionné ses joueurs par exemple il
vérifiait le compteur de leur voiture
pour savoir s'il était allé en boîte de
nuit en fait il faisait un peu le
gendarme ou le père de famille il
voulait de la discipline et des
comportements irréprochables
ça fait râler mais ça donnait des
résultats peut-être parce qu'au delà des
performances sportives et des coupes ce
qu'il cherchait c'était avant tout la
fierté et le respect des supporters ses
fans du club qui était prêt à manger des
pâtes pendant une semaine pour se payer
le billet d'entrée au stade est ce pour
cela que les critiques sur son
management un peu vieille école ne lui
faisait ni chaud ni froid posant lui la
question bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue guy roux merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ici au sénat
dans ce dom tournon est ce que c'est
pour ça que vous étiez dur avec les
joueurs est ce que c'était par respect
pour les supporters s'étaient pas le
respect par l' envie de réussir alors
bien sûr là le premier les premiers à
avoir être un peu récompensés c'étaient
les joueurs eux-mêmes les seconds le
club les gens qui financent ou qui se
dévouent ce moment là c'était surtout
des gens qui se dévoile et puis à cause
du principe que entraînements plus repos
égale forme l'entraînement c'était mon
métier j'essaye de me perfectionner
constamment en parcourant le monde dans
mes périodes de vacances allez voir les
les plus grands clubs du monde et puis
aussi parce que puisque entraînement
égale forme j'essayais de faire le
meilleur entraînement possible il
fallait qu'ils aient le meilleur propre
au site à partir de là si j'avais été
nul en entraînement je rétais
et parme et par mes employeurs
successifs
même dans le football amateur et e600 au
nul dans leur peau vient ça tape alors
comment on peut savoir c'est une m c'est
une période invisible l'entraînement le
retour on dit que c'est l'entraînement
invisible
y'a que les méthodes presque policière
qui permettent de savoir vous leur
faisait voir de toutes les couleurs à
ses joueurs un jeu le disait jusqu'à
espionner les compteurs de voitures pour
savoir s'il était léon boîte de nuit
vous aviez des indics au péage entre
auxerre et paris basile boli a dit un
jour je n'avais pas peur de mon père
j'avais peur de guy roux mais quel était
votre moyen de pression vous menaciez de
l'est de les virer du club non
en plus d'un en était le seul club par
exemple ne pas faire à ne pas faire d
amende dans tous les clubs
professionnels il ya des amendes même
les très grands
alors il n'ose pas les adaptant à la loi
permet pas de mettre des amendes à des
salariés alors le la des moyens par
exemple des grands clubs c'est de leur
verser une prime des tic paris saint
germain ont liquidé en prime des tic et
quand ils font un accro à l'éthique en
leur soi-disant lors aux tirs mais c'est
souvent avec sursis parce que les
joueurs sont suffisamment pour puissant
dans cette le bla pour empêcher alors
donc
moi je n'ai pas de repas d'amande alors
je leur faisais la gaule les gros yeux
et ça suffisait à les effrayer ces
grands joueurs les gros yeux avec
quelques compléments c'est à dire par
exemple les retards moi j'avais
cinq retard à l'entraînement parents
d'autoriser non en totalité dans le club
d'accord les joueurs totally alors je me
mettais à partir du mont les arrivées
par an si c'était 9 heures et demi je
mettais à 9 heures devant la porte
et donc j'ai salué commence à spa le
bébé a pleuré cette nuit là maman à ceci
ou la grand-mère quand je savais ce que
l'on sait tout dans un petit le métier
comme ça et donc tout d'un coup il y en
a un qui était en retard alors comme ils
ont chacun leur casier c'était tout le
monde attendait qu'il qu'il arrive parce
qu'il y avait une sorte de sketches si
ce joueur je mettais mon talon contre la
porte est donc celui qui était en retard
il n'était obligée de ce qu il importe
donc tout le monde t il à et attendait
et la différence avec les autres ces
jeux ne lui serrerait pas la main donc
ils allaient dans son casier se préparer
mais ils avaient rendez-vous à 11h45
avec moi dans mon bureau pour
m'expliquer car il est possible que
les
pépins dans la nuit si vous vers aux
excuses quand même s'il y en a de temps
en temps est ce que quand même il vous
est arrivé de sentir que vous étiez allé
trop loin
deux peut-être avoir des regrets
aujourd'hui est ce qui a eu un clash
avec un joueur une fois quelque chose
vous ai dit peut-être je suis un peu dur
en belgique lâcher les joueurs jamais eu
beaucoup parce que les joueurs vous avez
un effectif de 18 20 vous en avez 11 qui
jouent et alors il ya sans arrêt une
inflation au profit du au profit des
joueurs mais au début de ma carrière 7
et 11 11 qui font tout le match et quand
on avait un blessé qui n'avaient pas la
jambe cassée mais que tu es blessé on
faisait rester sur la ligne du milieu
pour tenir un joueur adverse pour que ça
fasse le compte bon après on a mis un
remplaçant deux remplaçants quatre
remplaçants mais maintenant c'est elle
s'est montée à 18 et en dans les coupes
mondiales ça va passer à 23 alors cette
inflation formidable fait que le nom
d'aimé côte en augmente vous avez aussi
des relations très privilégiées avec
avec certains joueurs vous avez tôt
notamment proche de basile boli une
réaction particulière aussi avec djibril
cissé il a préfacé votre livre
d'ailleurs confidences et il a dit un
jour que vous étiez le meilleur
entraîneur français
je crois que vous vous êtes occupé de
lui comme d'un fils voulu apporter des
repas quand il était malade est-ce que
parfois vous étiez un peu le père de ses
joueurs il ya des joueurs célèbres
qu'ils ont racontées donc je peux le
raconter aussi chiffo par exemple un
matin un dimanche matin pour les soins
n'est pas là c'est un exemplaire un
joueur exemplaire jamais on pouvait
supposer qu'il manque ou qu'ils soient
pas réveillé il était toujours trois
quarts d'heure en avance donc il est
malade donc j'ai fini l'entraînement
c'était un dimanche je suis allé chez
lui toute la famille malade 40 de fièvre
une bonne angine la dame la maman et la
petite fille bon alors qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai appelé le docteur
mais je savais les médicaments que le
docteur allait donner je suis allé à la
pharmacie chercher les médicaments après
avoir téléphoné au docteur mais j'avais
mes soins personnels la tisane ma grand
mère m'avait appris les bienfaits de la
tisane déjà les tisanes c'est de l'eau
et ils font quand on a de la fièvre et
une sudation donc il faut prendre des
choses voilà donc j'ai pris une marmite
jésus fait chauffer l'eau j'ai fait la
tisane alors si fo a raconté partout en
belgique je faisais la tees est-ce que
globalement vous diriez que il ya un
état d'esprit qui a changé dans les
clubs de foot aujourd'hui
est ce que les jeunes footballeurs
aujourd'hui manque de discipline manque
de cadres est ce que quel est votre
regard sur non ses joueurs aujourd'hui
moi je pense pas que c'est le fruit
aussi de d'études pas seulement ma
pensée mais c'est une opinion mon
opinion c'est que la jeunesse
on s'exprime quand on est adolescent
partout et toujours de la même manière
là je suis rousseauiste tous les enfants
naissent de bien et puis après c'est la
société qui ont fait des choses qu'il
est perverti qu'il est perverti ou qui
les met sur des voies royales et donc le
g7 opinion là je n'en change pas alors
on me dit oui mais c'est plus comme
avant cet or et attendrait mauger
j'étais avant puisque j'ai commencé en
preneur en 61 j'ai fini en 2006 alors
jeté avant pendant et après et après
j'ai pas eue en 2001 en 2009 à 9,61 à
une attitude un type d'adolescents puis
en 2006 des adolescents révolutionnaire
ou révolutionner complètement nouveau
nom j'ai ça c'est comment voulez vous
qu'ils soient de la même manière quand
il avait tout juste la tête c'est fait
aujourd'hui où ils ont 3 3 appareils sur
eux mêmes deux gros chez eux et il se
sert de tout ça donc dès qu'on leur
laisse le faire moi j'ai j'en ai jamais
pris avec un portable à l'entraînement
mais ça doit arriver de temps en temps
dans les centres de formation ce qui a
changé aussi guy roux c'est l'argent
quand même est-ce que alors c'est un
éternel débat sur cet argent qui
circulent dans le monde du football mais
puisque vous le dites vous même vous
avez connu toutes les époques et à une
époque où il y avait quand même moins
d'argent aujourd'hui y en a vraiment il
y en avait déjà aujourd'hui il y en a
vraiment vraiment beaucoup que vous
voulez qu'elle est liée à l'actualité le
meilleur club dur
c'était
kiev qui était dans l'ue et l'ukraine
étaient dans l'urne le meilleur joueur
le meilleur club du rsz c'était c'était
kiev est le meilleur joueur le meilleur
entraîneur stade lobanovski et
l'ailier droit de l'équipe blocs in de
l'équipe d'urss eh bien ils n'étaient
plus payés que le secrétaire général du
parti communiste d'ukraine
qui faisait qui gérait le niveau de paye
il avait éprouvé le besoin de payer de
faire payer puisque c'était tout c'était
communiste c'était de faire payer son
joueur son meilleur joueur celui qui
était aimé par tout le monde de le faire
payer de plus que la vitesse que vous
voulez dire voulait dire que parce
qu'ils apportent beaucoup de bonheur ses
joueurs il mérite ce soit là et ça a
toujours existé on a créé le
professionnalisme en 1930 où 33 en
france pour arrêter les abus de paiement
sous la table et non fiscalisés et dès
les premiers joueurs dès les premiers
matches
les anglais qui ont éprouvé le besoin de
faire apprendre ils avaient leurs
apprentis dans les usines ils avaient
leurs apprentis sous 2
fraser footballeur bon ben c'est les
footballeurs que telle et pourtant il
faisait quelque chose qui ressemblait à
du le plaisir tout le temps sauf quand
on leur faisait laver les chaussures des
vedettes du club ou bien faire le ménage
dans l'est dans tous les endroits où
améliorer le terrain alors ne parlons
plus des joueurs aujourd'hui l' aj
auxerre c'est un milliardaire chinois je
crois qui en est actionnaire principal
ils s'appellent james où il a créé dans
les années 80 une société spécialisée
dans l'emballage de produits pas
tellement de rapport avec le foot c'est
pas grave ça non plus
bas on lui demande pas non plus d'être
bon en football on lui demande de savoir
gérer après vous avez un bon patron ou
mauvais patrons mais vous ne vous sentez
pas déposséder sépare de la france à
l'otan ces bijoux vous avez employé le
mot
l'association chez nous à aux alentours
de 8% des actions mais s'il fait monter
la valeur du club par exemple et qu'il
vend nous aurons lui pour ça on est
mieux à warluis % de bons coups que vous
ressentez peu la coupe du monde de foot
au qatar elle vous gêne pas alors il ya
beaucoup de critiques autour de cette
coupe du monde de ce mondial qui arrive
on parle d' aberration écologique d'
aberration sociale et humaine d'après
the guardian 6500 travailleurs migrants
seraient morts sur les chantiers de
construction des stades il ya même des
appels au boycott vous allez y aller
vous je sais pas ce que j'ai un âge le
climat ne me plaît pas je le dirai
peut-être pas j'irai peut-être aura
match ou plus long ou la demi finale
comme j'ai été la dernière fois ci le
président de la république m'invite dans
son avion
alors réfléchissons c'est l'écologie je
refuse ce
bon on peut dire qu'on va consommer du
carbone pour faire du froid
de toute façon dans tous ces pays là ils
en font du froid alors ils vont en faire
un peu plus pour rafraîchir les terrains
de jeu on va quand même pas chipoter
pour ça pour ce qui concerne les les
mettez les décès et les blessés bien sûr
c'est très regrettable mais alors quand
vous regardez ces pays où quand vous y
allez comment ils ont fait les tours de
800 mètres les tours de 300 mètres il
n'y a pas eu d'accident là dedans alors
tout d'un coup on leur a donné du
travail il y avait ça ils ont oublié des
enfants du népal dit moi je suis là les
uns kong plusieurs fois à des congrès
là-bas de de prestige aux dirigeants de
football
les gens qui s'occupaient de la chambre
par exemple c'était un népalais qui
vivait à 6000 m il rentrait chez lui
tous les deux ans mais nourrissait il
avait malgré ça quand même beaucoup
d'enfants et nourrissait sa famille avec
des salaires qui par rapport à la valeur
de sa monnaie et est somptueux il
n'allait pas se plaindre bon d'accord il
risquait pas sa vie en faisant ma
chambre mais
les métiers tous les métiers sont
exercés dans ces pays là et notamment
les métiers de maçonnerie les métiers de
construction croyez-vous qu'on a
construit le sénat sans aucun accident
du travail non dire où va s'arrêter sur
votre vie votre parcours et sur ce qui
vous a amené à cette passion pour le
foot comment le fils de colonel se
retrouve dans un stade à regarder des
matchs de colmar comment vous en êtes
arrivés là c'est pas tout à fait lié à
ma naissance sauf que
dana un problème de santé dans ma
famille email vais à appoigny dans
l'yonne a été tel que ma famille ne
pouvait plus avoir plusieurs enfants en
charge et que j'étais
remis sûrement dans ma ville de
naissance chez un ami de mon grand père
qui était maraîcher alsacien et le
premier dimanche ces gens qui est
extrêmement gentil était à table et
j'apprends j'aimais déjà le football je
l'avais appris à l'aimer à poigne in
avec mes copains et leur papa non
prisonnier
jeudi un jeu il ya match de première
division je vais aller le voir alors
c'était à 3 km donc je suis sorti de
table j'ai rien dit et j'ai couru les
trois kilomètres derrière un vélo qui y
allait je voulais entrer c'était gratuit
pour les enfants sauf qu'il fallait pas
il fallait être accompagnés j'ai attrapé
le manteau d'un monsieur grands qui s'en
est pas aperçu
je suis entrée dans le stade il n'y
avait pas des barrières je suis allé
derrière le but j'ai ramassé les balles
pendant le match le gardien de but qui
s'appelait monsieur ange elle m'a pris
en sympathie j'étais tout petit en plus
je suis pas très grand mais des
tout-petits et vous devenez ramasseur de
balles alors je deviens ramasseurs de
balle toute l'année mais j'allais à
l'entraînement le jeudi c'était le jeudi
d'un ce temps là les je ramassais les
balles le jeudi je tapais dedans aussi
et je après après l'entraînement des
pros j'allais jouer d'autres gamins je
joue et je peux aller à colmar
aujourd'hui sur le mur du temple il y
avait un but à la craie il a été repeint
ya pas longtemps cg jouer partout où on
pouvait jouer au ballon
je suis je suis revenu 3 après pour ça
allait mieux dans ma famille être en
quatrième aube lycée jacques amyot
d'auxerre il y avait les pensionnaires
je suis j'ai accepté d'être mentionnait
parce qu'il y avait deux récré on
faisait des matches et la balle était
dans mon cas ici et vous allez en 1950
retournez donc vous l'avez dit vivre
dans l'aude dans l'yonne et là vous
allez faire vos débuts d'entraîneur et
moi j'ai une archive à vous montrer
alors elle va peut-être pas vous dire
grand chose là comme ça mais je vais
expliquer je vais vous expliquer je vais
expliquer aux gens qui nous écoutent
synarchiste qui nous a été transmise par
les archives nationales qui sont nos
partenaires sur cette émission c'est la
liste des stagiaires présents au stage
national d'entraîneur de l'institut
national des sports du 27 mai au 11 juin
1974 votre nom y figure et parmi les
encadrants il y avait michel hidalgo
incertain de michel hidalgo futur grand
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france ces
deux ans après qu'il devient
sélectionneur ça évoque des souvenirs ce
stage oui absolument surtout que surtout
qu'ils aient disparu après
dernières années très difficiles et je
gt gt devenu dans la vie d'abord j'avais
et étudiants avec sa femme à limoges et
puis
il a il était mon maître dont on n'était
pas honnête et 140 ont noté par équipes
de 14 ou 15 et donc j'étais dans son
équipe donc il m'a enseigné pendant un
mois trente et un jours c'était 31 jours
dimanche compris c'était tout le mois de
juillet et deux ans après il devient
sélectionneur de france vous aviez rêvé
d'être sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france ou pas parce que on vous l'a
proposé se passer ces deux fois enfin
proposé n'a pas écrit comme la dent la
bonde amendis alors là la première fois
j'étais sous contrat
non j'étais libre je dire et j'ai refusé
d'y aller parce que c'était 94 et je
sentais que j'aurais une très grosse
équipe avec mes jeunes qui avait 17 ans
quand il arrivera à maturité j'ai eu la
très grosse équipe j'ai pu faire le
doublé
casillas un club en france qu'on fait le
doublé donc vaut certes plutôt que le
pays quoi sert fêteront et puis je me
demandais toujours il ya six matches par
an huit matches par an qu'est ce que je
vais faire les autres matin et ça ça me
hante est jeune et maillet on ne lui
fera des conférences de froissy du
fossat bon et puis quand même j'ai mûri
et on veut la reproposer aimé jacquet
avant 81 18 champions du monde
déjà c'était dans une autre partie de
d'âge et de sa carrière c'est votre
contrat du directeur technique national
et là il y avait vraiment un poste mais
j'étais saoul contre elle m'a dit ça
très simple il m'a dit guy moi j'ai
toujours respecté votre contrat
respectez le vôtre mais comme vaut mieux
deux précautions qu'une les dirigeants
de la js sont allés voir le président de
la fédération lundi ouvre ton tiroirs
sort le contractual homologué de guiron
et de l'aj auxerre et a pas le droit de
proposer un poste avec des roues vous
êtes quand même un peu sélectionneur
d'une équipe de france mais c'est celle
de l'assemblée nationale moi je les
découverts en préparant cet entretien
puisque vous avez entraîné xavier
bertrand françois baroin renault mise et
me renaud muselier c'étaient eux les
meilleurs alors
françois oui oui si c'était parmi les
meilleurs
on y avait aussi le
olivier le vérin
ministre et ancien ministre de la santé
oui j'y verrai way oui c'est ça le
ministre a fait le plus d'heures de
télévision dans l'eau pendant deux ans
et edouard philippe aussi à jouer
arrière central olivier ferrand qui est
venu en campagne électorale a aussi il
se comportait bien tous alors là les
avancées tels le lei avait le sénat avec
ses terres
les parlementaires le club alors on
jouait contre les variétés et c'est pour
alimenter une caisse médical de
chercheurs de il y avait des lobbyistes
qui trouver des sponsors ça faisait une
somme en faisait la photo avec les
joueurs mais parce que le le
les gens de l'équipe adverse c'était
d'aider l'équipe de france de 98
compromet alors des scores de 12-11 12
étaient fréquents on a fait une fois 5 à
5 mais ce que j'avais renforcer l'équipe
à peu en douce avec deux trois
professionnels pas en douce voilà bon
j'étais content alors c'était cette
équipe daou il y avait des sénateurs
j'avais peur d'en perdre autour de l'eau
médicalement je leur disais toujours et
vous fascine visite quand est-ce alors
quand avez vous joué la dernière fois à
ben c'était ça va être c'était un
alsacien c'était pour l'inauguration du
terrain c'était convertissent 970 ah bon
dire où j'ai envie qu'on parle un peu de
l'actualité du football l'actualité très
récente ce qui s'est passé des choses du
côté de l' aj auxerre ça ne vous a pas
échappé l' aj auxerre qui revient aux
ligue 1 après dix ans en ligue 2 qu'est
ce que ça vous a fait de devoir ce club
votre club votre club de coeur revenir
en ligue 1 sans vous aux commandes ben
non ça fait longtemps j'ai quitté en
2006 1 ça fait donc fait la soustraction
hier je dois dire je suis pas allé au
match que j'ai un peu fatigué mon coeur
avec toutes mes activités on a même un
moment de la sortie on me l'a mis à 7
degrés on l'a remis donc je fais
attention donc on m'a dit attention pas
d'émotions extraordinaire bon alors un
match comme ça
donc j'avais été bien au match aller
parce que je me disais il ya le match
retour toute façon y aura pas le revenu
ta non match retour j'ai eu peur je suis
pas allé à saint-etienne et c'est moi
j'ai regardé le match tranquille tout
seul et puis avec des pilules à côté
quand même et puis quand on a marqué de
but jusqu'au but 52e minute j'étais
calme aucune accélération cardiaque et
là j'ai mis mes tennis et je suis parti
j'ai fait trois kilomètres n'ont pas de
footing mais de marche je suis revenu
pour les prolongations mais pourquoi
vous aviez peur que ça je vais faire de
m'exciter trop de me mettre en danger et
alors là quand je suis revenu j'avais
laissé ma télé allumée j'ai vu que vous
préparez les prolongations à l'est les
villes prolongation je regardais et puis
après les penaltys ça m'a rien fait et
alors et j'avais confiance et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous avez hâte
et j'avais confiance parce que j'avais
étudié les conditions psychologiques de
l'équipe adverse comme si j'étais
l'entraîneur
j'ai dit si si on a pas sinon pas de 0
ou 3 0 après vous en avoir peur le
public était qui les soutenaient si ils
sentaient en eux mêmes qu'ils allaient
se faire croquer ce qui s'est en fait un
peu produits j'ai des photos pour vous
maintenant guiraud on change de chapitre
c'est la séquence photos de notre
émission et je commence par cette photo
c'est emmanuel macron qui exprime sa
joie lors de la finale du mondial de
2018 en russie vous en avez vu passer un
des présidents jacques chirac nicolas
sarkozy le premier vous a fait chevalier
de la légion d'honneur le second vous a
promu officier le qu'elle aimait le plus
le foot détroit ouais ben là j'étais à
20 mètres de lui quand il fait cette
crotte cette photo est prise ce jour-là
c'est lui qui
malheureusement d'ailleurs parce que les
autres n'étaient plus là mais non
monsieur sarkozy aime beaucoup le foot
c'est une constante ans chez les
précieuses alors je vous dire j'ai pas
pourquoi je sais depuis très longtemps
qu'ils aiment le foot c'est quinze jours
au parc des princes est en avance pour
voir jouer le l'ancien p de monsieur
bourelly il était le maire de neuilly et
m'a fait garder ses enfants de cinq ans
pendant qu'ils allaient voir un électeur
un peu plus loin donc je sais qu'il aime
le foot je sais je sais que monsieur
chirac les mets un peu dans dans son
pays parfois ils allaient au match de
son village mais bon qui connaissait pas
trop qu'ils avaient beaucoup étudié de
choses mais pas trop le football et le
troisième c'est monsieur macron monsieur
macron à mon avis j'ai vu jouer loi le
match où il a joué blé avec les variétés
il a dû jouer jusqu'en seconde et en
première
pendant les récrés et puis pendant les
séances de gym et peut-être en
championnat scolaire c'est possible elle
est une deuxième photo eric cantona
révélé l aj auxerre grâce à vous je
crois que c'est un copain ouvriers qui
vous téléphone un jour en vous disant
écoute ya un phénomène extraordinaire il
s'appelle cantona vous lui demander de
trouver le nom du président de son club
de son éducateur l'adresse de ses
parents leur métier le dimanche suivant
vous étiez aux caillols un quartier de
marseille pour voir les parents de
cantona et vous ne l'avez plus haché je
crois qu'un mois plus tard il était chez
vous c'est ça oui parce qu'on n'était
pas allés plus les plus fortunés
pourraient faire briller les yeux de sa
famille qui et ses grands-parents et
emma sont ses parents
infirmiers et puis le perd un peu
peintre aussi ce qui lui a donné envie
de faim alors l'argent jeu ça compte
pour les parents aussi et il y avait
plein tous les clubs le savais qu'il
était bon alors j'ai décidé
et puis il est venu faire un stage il
avait fait des stages déjà à nice que ça
lui avait bien plus sales il l'a dit
dans son livre
me l'a pas dit à moi il a dans son livre
i amis qu'il aurait bien été à nice
parce que c'est pas loin de chez son
grand père et puis il est venu il est
venu chez nous parce que le dernier jour
du stage il m'a dit monsieur est ce que
je pourrais avoir un maillot et moi
j'avais préparé un colis avec un maillot
et je lui ai donné à nice il lui a dit
vas voir la boutique s'élabore c'est
payant violent et c'est comme ça que
vous le convaincre une dernière photo
jamel debbouze qui peut paraître
surprenant pour ceux qui nous écoutent
on ne présente plus un jamel debbouze
mais vous vous connaissez bien vous avez
une relation franchement amical dites
vous et la première fois que vous le
rencontrez je crois que c'est dans un
hôtel à chablis comme d'habitude vous
faites le tour des chambres pour
vérifier que les joueurs sont bien dans
leur chambre au repos justement sauf que
là il n'y sont pas ils sont pas dans
leur chambre et vous entend des rires
vous entendez un peu glousser et vous
arrivez auprès d'eux et c'est jamel
debbouze qui est en train de tester ses
sketches auprès des joueurs mais par
téléphone et alors qu'est ce qui se
passe le téléphone avec un amplificateur
ouais ils sont tous dans la dans la
chambre plié de rire et c'est l'heure où
il devrait être dans leur chambre à
dormir alors là vous criez vous criez
pas ben moi je m'assois jury aussi guy
roux une dernière question qui est en
lien avec notre lieu le lieu dans lequel
on se trouve on est entouré de quatre
statues qui représentent chacune une
vertu on en a une qui représente la
sagesse une autre qui représente la
prudence une autre ici qui représente la
justice est derrière moi l'éloquence est
ce qu'il ya une de ses vertus l'angle
éloquence l'éloquence qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est la vertu qui vous parle le
plus ou qui vous caractérise le plus
peut-être la sagesse la prudence la
justice ou l'éloquence
la justice à ces la justice
le lot quand je la mettrais quatre lits
la dernière merci merci infiniment guy
roux d'avoir été notre avis et nous
avoir livré votre monde est votre regard
merci à vous et merci à vous qui nous
regardent et à très bientôt sur public
sénat
[Musique]